- Hey guys, real quick,
wanted to just make a quick one off video,
which is something we have just not been
doing quite a bit of,
and it's very simple, it's
this thought process of
you find what you're looking for.
I've been giving a lot of thought to
kind of just watching
what I'm seeing out there
in the social, digital, eco system,
and very honestly, just real life.
And I'm watching so many people
over the last two to three years
look for negativity, look
for something that's wrong,
find where people
disagree with them, fight,
look for woe is me,
downside, half glass empty.
And then I go to a Twitter
search or look around the world
and I find ridiculously
beautiful things every day.
Every day thousands of kind
acts, randomly, by people.
People that I have
conversations with who see
the opportunities,
whether it's in business,
like voice, and AR, or
crypto, whatever it may be.
Just this amazingly interesting thing
that I feel the majority of
you are looking for the wrong
while there's plenty of wrong
and plenty of right in the world.
It comes down to one very simple thing.
What are you choosing to look for?
Because I promise you, if you right now,
and I'm making this video for one reason,
24 hours of trying to find the good.
Somebody saves a kitten,
somebody opens the door,
somebody does a nice thing for you,
somebody says thank you, 24
hours of looking for positivity
could change your life.
Honestly, making this
for one fucking person.
One.
One person watches this
video, chooses to do 24 hours
of looking for good
instead of looking for bad,
and their game changes.
Drock heard somebody at a
convenient store saying,
"Mom you're always so negative,
you're always so negative."
I am blown away by the fact
that life gets real simple
if you break down to this.
Are you looking for the negative?
This sucks, this government sucks,
this person sucks, this is fucked.
Or are you looking for the positive?
She's nice, that's remarkable,
I've got this opportunity.
You choose what you're looking for.
Because what you look for, you find.
That's how fucking life works.